[Applause]
now jason uh congratulations of course
you're getting a lot of attention for
your joe biden
impression on turn out live thank you
very much did you always do a joe bike
for years when you were a kid after
years uh but or did
how hard did you have to work on this
impression literally we did one last
year
uh uh for the halloween show is him
dressed up
for something and so i just did like
three lines and then over the summer
uh when he was named the vice president
nominee i remembered
that i was doing joe biden that i had
done him because i got texts from people
at the show saying hey congrats
yeah i was like congrats why oh oh right
i do joe biden
sure so so then uh and then uh yeah and
then i watched a lot of youtube
throughout this last week to sort of try
studied him yeah
it's all the teeth it's all it's all
teeth like like
i don't have uh joe biden teeth like
when i smile like
if like if i just smile normally you
know right
it's all gums you get a lot of gum yeah
no teeth whatsoever
so then so then they were very nice i
even brought them with me because i
carry them with me all the time i write
them
on the subway but look at this right
here
there you go there they are there he is
those are overpowering shows
look at that oh man you guys
show up on the wide angle too look at
that hey those are beautiful yeah
all right all right now uh do you did
you get a lot of feedback
on that sketch we just watched a little
clip of it yeah i mean from like friends
out of nowhere um you know and uh um
most of it positive i did however get
one one guy that was a little upset at
me i actually
actually have it here on myspace
everybody at myspace right you know
myspace right
uh people can get a hold of you people
can get ahold of me and let you know
their feelings and uh
what was it that uh that bothered him it
was like the run there about about uh
scranton pennsylvania about it it being
a
a jerk water of a town is he from
scranton yeah yeah i i'm guessing that's
where he's from but yeah
his name's pete uh and the subject this
is real this really happened
uh the subject was eat me
um and then this is this is this is what
he says uh if you have a problem with
scranton
why don't you come out and say it to my
face you know talent hack
[Applause]
fair hit yeah uh i get a lot of these
yeah i believe it yeah yeah uh it's
funny that i had to see the scranton
skit on the internet since i thought snl
was canceled
years ago turns out it's still on it
just sucks
why don't you take a long swim in the
east river before you do be sure to
strap 200 pounds of bricks to your back
before you jump in
but then these signs off biting
yeah there's pete right there's pete
let's see peter
nice looking guy i don't know he's
i like he wrote that all right and
that's like time for a photo to go with
oh okay
i'm gonna put on my best dust yeah i
mean it looks like a really nice guy and
i can't fault him for loving his town i
mean obviously i i mean i i do want to
say
pete in all sincerity i've never been uh
to uh
scranton uh but i respect the fact that
you like it and i'm sorry for any uh
upsetting you in any way
i actually did not write that um the
writer that did
uh here's his email address uh it's
scranton sucks big ones that
so the best way to it's best yeah just
go right to him
yeah then petey
petey now uh yeah of course uh tina fey
getting a lot of attention yeah
for her governor palin she's a great
governor pal absolutely no i mean she
needs the dough she had to come back
you know she was desperate after that
didn't even look anything like her but
it's sad um oh it's fantastic it's such
a such a
a buzz saw as i stay in the sports world
to be up there that's so nerve-wracking
i was like
she's so great at it and like so and
looks just like her and sounds just like
her and it's such a fun take and i was
like
oh i hope that this doesn't go as i'm
thinking it might where she says stuff
and everybody laughs and then i say
stuff
nobody says anything or doing not even
looking me just waiting for her to talk
again or something
be awful people love the teeth they love
the teeth uh now
what i'm curious about something you a
lot of when i worked at startup live
years ago
one of the best things is all the cool
people that would show up to do it here
you are you guys are satirizing a
presidential campaign
and these people actually show up right
have you have you gotten a chance to
really meet or get to know
uh barack obama or john mccain well not
i don't know if i got to know him
necessarily i mean i get it i get it i
get it
yeah but um
that's okay i got it i don't need to
shake your hand i get it that's all
right
uh i i met uh barack obama with that
same sketch where i was dressed as joe
biden
um we met him uh there real nice guy
good eye contact good handshake looks
good in a suit
yep um and then yeah exactly
got it all three boxes um checked uh and
then then john mccain was on last year
and uh in between uh the dress show
which we do before the live show
uh there's a meeting in in lauren's
office and uh it's like 50 of us all
sitting around you may
remember this in a tiny rainy room
people are like squeezed in i sit on a
stair like a step just like this down
here
uh really copying a squat literally like
it looks like i'm about to
take a dump and uh and uh uh
so i'm you know what i mean right why no
i don't it's just that's the position
i'm in yes okay and
um but it's only funny because at this
point john mccain comes walking over
because there's an empty spot next to me
sits right down next to me like like
we're like two little kids with our
knees like right by our chin
and and i'm wearing ku basketball shorts
kansas university basketball shorts
which i wear in between the shows just
because it's uh
comfortable and he starts talking to me
about uh uh you know kansas basketball
and like arizona basketball
and uh luke olsen i think was their
their coach there and all and all this
stuff anyway
uh we're talking while lauren is giving
our boss is giving us notes trying to
tell us the changes that are about to
happen in the live show so take care
lauren can be intimidating in this
meeting extremely intimidating yeah he's
making quick changes you i mean 30
minutes before this thing's about to go
out to millions and millions of people
and john mccain is just like you know
how about how about the k.u
you know jayhawks you know and then lewd
olson and all this and i'm like
we're gonna get busted like you can't
you can't we're supposed to be paying
attention sir but then i realized
i'm not gonna get in trouble what's he
gonna like lauren's not gonna yell at
john mccain i'm in the clear
yeah i was like you want to share what
you're talking about about with the rest
of the class i was like we're talking
about foreign policy
leave us alone don't worry about it
we're figuring it out
don't worry about your silly skits
uh now i wish i had been there for that
uh
when i was a writer there and again this
is a long time ago back when it was you
know mostly a radio show but
uh i i had when i was a writer there now
if it's still the same i had a legal pad
and i would write all my ideas down and
i was always carrying my legal pad
around and looking through my legal pad
to see what ideas and a lot of those oh
you have it i have a little tiny pad
okay this is my this is this is this is
what i use now a lot of mine ended up
being ideas that never got on the show
yeah that's what this is that's what
that's what this is mostly phone numbers
and addresses but every now and then
yeah like like here what do we got here
buy a bong talk show
i don't know i don't know i don't i
don't even know what it means
it might be two separate thoughts
i don't know
we got oh here's the catch phrase i know
that because it's in quotes
uh it says that's how i roll just the
character that says that's how i roll a
lot
all right again this is why they're in
the book and not on the show oh here we
go
here we go see this is a commercial this
must be a butt mouth
if your mouth is going to act like a
butt then you got to treat it like one
and you know what this was this was for
this is for like toothpaste mouth wipes
like like this or an actual invention
that you're either way you really
if it's good enough you can do both yeah
i think
it might actually be oh yeah there's a
trademark that must be a real
item that i'm thinking about doing
there's a pat i got a patent on it so
you carry these around and when you're
in trouble at staring out live you pull
that book out and you look for an idea
yeah when in the last ditch effort yeah
absolutely uh when i
they would have a meeting on monday
night yeah at the show and that's where
you had to tell
the host what your idea was and i don't
know if it's still the same but the
writers never have any ideas on monday
nights
and they go to this meeting and i always
used to pretend
every week i said the same thing which
was insert the host's name
into you own a dirigible a zeppelin
right
and it's all about you owning a zeppelin
but it was complete non-ideal so i was
like george what's your and lauren would
say what's your idea for george went
right george went you own a zeppelin
[Laughter]
then the next week what's your idea for
donald trump donald trump you own a
zeppelin
and it was my way of getting through the
meeting and then i realized everybody
was doing the same thing
no one starts to write that show till
friday morning absolutely
it's so true absolutely and donald trump
probably was like no i do own a lot of
zappos yeah
i don't see how that's funny uh
what's wrong with the billionaire having
zeppelins
uh jumps off and screaming
oh man oh here we go
what is um is the rest of your family
are they uh
are they funny people i think so yeah i
mean i find them to be really uh very
very funny
are they in comedy or are they don't
know my i have two younger sisters one
is uh
one is a dancer choreographer here in
town and what kind of uh choreography
and dance
like um like drill teams like dance
teams for high schools and
then also like contemporary stuff like
you would see on like something like so
you think you can dance
uh but um but and then my youngest
sister
lindsay is a nun she's a nun so really
yeah wow yeah so i guess she's kind of
an actor
we all perform in a certain way i mean
you know she like you know i try to get
jokes across kristen's trying to get
dance across and lindsay's trying to get
you know the word of god across yes well
there you go that was nice that's what
he meant
in case she was faking it she really
believes in it
sorry if it came out that way linds
sorry oh boy
uh now sorry does she does she watch
saturday night live does your sister
who's a nun watching
on occasion when she's back home at my
folks they they don't have it in the uh
in the convent
uh they have yet to get tivo in the
convent for some reason
uh but uh but she watches back home
she's she's somewhat approving
you know what happens when there's
something on that's kind of racy or
you know uh your appearance here tonight
which has been filthy uh what
exactly what uh what how will she how
does she respond she breaks out the butt
mouth wipes and tells me to wash up no
uh she uh literally she turns into like
a 90 year old
nun and just gives me a little chase
that's it it's very clear literally
literally a task test test known jason
you don't have to be blue to be funny
she's very she's very sweet and you say
no i do i do i
do then i pop in the teeth i go hey look
at me
i don't know she probably hangs out with
pete
do you think she helped pete write that
letter to you not with some of that
language no no
no i think pete had his own help and
we're gonna hear from pete
trust me there's a good chance of it
saturday night live weekend
update thursday airs live thursday night
this thursday night
at 9 30 on nbc the show's doing great
everyone's talking about it
congratulations to you
you're a good man thanks for coming by
like ones jason sedakis everybody we'll
be right back